here's a deacon what guests had to say
after the show ask Jennifer what impact
do you think Michigan's recent passage
of right-to-work laws will have on the
state's economy
in general and especially on working
people well they said that it was going
to create great economic boom and in
fact we've lost jobs since since they
adopted it so and what does that mean
right-to-work does means that you
basically right it's anti-union it
basically says that you don't when you
work in a in a shop that is represented
by unions you don't have to sign up it
was a way it has been a way in Michigan
Wisconsin and other states to diminish
the ranks of the Union workforce and I
think politically it was done to to
really make sure that the unions and the
working people don't have a voice as
much politically either because you
can't organize as well when you can't
ensure that you've got a robust Union
presence mandatory you don't have an
option of whether or not you want to
join a union in Wisconsin that was the
issue they just take the money out or
does the money go it goes to Democratic
campaign coffers in Wisconsin which is
close to Michigan they've managed to do
pension reform and Union pension reform
and there they've reduced completely
eradicated their debts grown jobs and if
not raised taxes they're just they just
fallen way behind in Minnesota but other
than that that which is a good boost I
mean it's just it's an effort to take
away the power of people against those
who want to reduce wages and reduce
pensions etc minutes that's really what
it is it's a way to reduce costs so that
you don't have to pay for it and you
know the question is as a nation is that
a good thing does it continue to
exacerbate the hollowing out of the
middle class I would say it absolutely
does when you don't you take away the
voice of people from being able to
organize you diminish their power you
diminish their wages okay why do
Republicans and Democratic parties
create rules to keep third party
candidates from debates let's just file
that under obvious reasons we really
need to answer that question I think
that the third party at the presidential
level as a president Commission and
third parties do get to debate Ross
Perot yeah it was that 92 yeah I got a
plan think I have stops percent in the
polls that's not right
the reason is is every kook in the world
the president right remember the rents
too damn high but that party he'd be be
in there I wish he was in a funny do you
see any new technology on the horizon
such as artificial intelligence that
could change or influence how political
campaigns are run normal intelligence
smartly these days okay and I'm looking
at Steve and I know this because we do
it for a living
now he runs smart campaigns yes he has a
thing for like ball headed guys you know
miss mr. Carville what Republican
politicians do you respect and MS Matlin
same question for you regarding
Democratic poll I would say something
but that would probably ruin their
chances there for a Republican primary
you know well it's easier a lot of them
that I like but you know
let me of them a lot of them I shouldn't
like I met Chris Christie a couple times
he's really a kind of a nice guy to
shoot the breeze with Ross Scott Walker
he's a piece of good guy yeah he's a
pretty nice guy you disagree with him
but Jeb Bush Johnny Isakson in any
number Lindsey Graham about know them
talk to them and everything they seem
much more reasonable off camera yeah I
think so I'm the same off-camera admire
I adore is Mitch Landrieu who's about to
be reelected the mayor of your town and
fifteen seven years ago we're 15 feet
underwater now we're number one in the
country we had a little blackout at the
Superbowl as he said who hasn't blacked
out of New Orleans that's right Mitch
Landrieu you guys moved to New Orleans
are you much happier they're getting out
of the deal always happy why do you
think leader I haven't just gonna read
the book that's why
and here's a passage you know you were
talking about when when he was riding
high and and you weren't and you said
and while I was adjusting to life
without a job and days without purpose
James was beating off I'm sorry James
was beating off endless opportunities
the French had the saying [ __ ] like a
bald man Real Time with Bill Maher ask
villainous guests your questions right
after the show at HBO calm or on Twitter